colleagues why don't we take our seats
the Senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will lead us in
prayer
let us pray Lord through all the
generations you have been our mighty God
as millions mourn the deaths of Coby and
Gianna Bryant and those who died with
them we think about life's brevity
uncertainty and legacy remind us that we
all have a limited time on earth to
leave the world better than we found it
as this impeachment process unfolds give
our senators the desire to make the most
of their time on earth teach them how to
live Oh God and lead them along the path
of honesty may they hear the words of
Jesus of Nazareth reverberating down the
corridors of the centuries and you shall
know the truth and the truth shall make
you free and Lord thank you for giving
our chief justice
another birthday amen
please join me in reciting the pledge of
allegiance to our flag
if there is no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date without objection so ordered the
sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation very hear ye hear ye all
persons are commanded to keep silent on
pain of imprisonment while the Senate of
the United States is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States
Chief Justice the majority leader is
recognized as the chaplains indicated on
behalf of Allah a happy birthday I'm
sure this is exactly how you plan to
celebrate the day well thank you very
much for those kind wishes and thank you
to all the senators for not asking for
the yeas and nays
and for the information of all centers
we should expect a break every two or
three hours and then a 6 o'clock a break
for dinner and with that mr. chief
justice our uniform pursuant to the
provisions of Senate resolution 483 the
counsel for the president have twenty
two hours and five minutes remaining to
make the presentation of their case the
Senate will now hear you Thank You mr.
Chief Justice members of the Senate
managers what we've done on Saturday is
the pattern that we're going to continue
today as far as how we're going to deal
with the case we deal with transcript
evidence we deal with publicly available
information we do not deal with
speculation allegations that are not
based on evidentiary standards at all we
are going to highlight some of those
very facts we talked about very quickly
on Saturday you're going to hear more
about that I want to give you a little
bit of an overview of what we plan to do
today in our presentation you will hear
from a number of lawyers each one of
these lawyers will be addressing a
particular aspect of the president's
case I will introduce the issues that
they're going to discuss and then that
individual lawyer will come up and make
their presentation we want to do this on
a expeditious but yet thorough basis let
me start with just for a very brief few
moments to take a look at where we were
one of the things that became very clear
to us as we looked at the presentation
from the house managers was the lack of
focus on that July 25th transcript and
that's because the transcript actually
doesn't say
what they would like it to say now we've
heard and you will hear more about that
in the days ahead we know about mr.
ships version of the transcript you
heard it you saw it I want to keep
coming back to facts facts that are
really undisputed the president in his
conversation was clear on a number of
points but so was presidents of liske I
mentioned that at the close of my
arguments earlier that it was president
szalinski that said no pressure I didn't
feel any pressure and again is this kind
of reading of minds of what were people
were saying I think we need to look at
what they actually said and how it's
backed up it is our position as a
president's council that the president
was all time acting under his
constitutional authority under his legal
authority in our national interest and
pursuant to his oath of office asking a
foreign leader to get to the bottom of
issues of corruption is not a violation
of an oath
it was interesting because there was a
lot of discussion the other day about
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh and one of
the things that we reiterate is that he
himself said there was he did not know
if there was anything of a crime or
anything of that nature he had deep
policy concerns and I think that is what
this is really about is deep policy
concerns deep policy differences we live
in a constitutional republic where you
have deep policy concerns and deep
differences that should not be the basis
of an impeachment if the bar of
impeachment has now reached that level
then for the sake of the Republic the
danger that puts not just this body but
our entire constitutional framework in
is unmanageable are we can have every
time there's a policy difference of
significance or an approach difference
of significance about a policy
we're gonna start an impeachment
proceeding being on as I said earlier I
don't really think this was about just a
phone call there was a pattern in
practice of attempts over a three-year
period to not only interfere with the
president's capability to govern which
by the way they were a completely
unsuccessful at just look at the state
of where we are as a country but also
interfere with our constitutional
framework I'm gonna say this because I
want to be brief we are going to have a
series of lawyers address you so will
not be one lawyer for hours and hours
we're gonna have a series of lawyers
address you on a variety of issues this
is how we envision the president's
defense going we thought it would be
appropriate to start with an overview if
you will of some of the significant
historical issues and constitutional
issues involving impeachment proceedings
since we don't have a long history of
that and I think that's good for the
country that we don't and I think we
would all agree but if this becomes the
new standard the future is going to look
a lot different so we're gonna hear next
from my co-counsel judge Kenneth Starr
judge Starr is a former judge for the US
Court of Appeals for the District of
Columbia he serves the 39th Solicitor
General of the United States arguing
cases before the Supreme Court of the
United States on behalf of the United
States I had the privilege of arguing a
case alongside judge Starr we were
talking about earlier many years ago he
also served as the independent counsel
during the Clinton presidency and
authored the Starr report he testified
for almost 12 hours before the Judiciary
Committee with regard to the
Report Judge Starr is very familiar with
this process he is going to address a
series of deficiencies there's legal
issues with regard to articles 1 & 2
constitutional implications historical
implications and legal implications of
where this case now stands so I would
like to yield my time right now to if it
would please chief justice Kenneth Starr
Thank You mr. chief justice
house managers and staff members of the
Senate the majority leader and the
Minority Leader at the beginning of
these proceedings on January 16 the
Chief Justice administered the oath of
office to the members of this body and
then again on Tuesday in doing so the
Chief Justice was honoring the words of
our Constitution article 1 section 3 we
all know the first sentence of that
article by heart the Senate shall have
the sole power to try all impeachments
but then the constitutional text goes on
to say this when sitting for that
purpose they shall be on earth both or
affirmation that oath or affirmation in
turn requires each member of the Senate
to do impartial justice
now this constitutionally administered
oath or affirmation has been given in
every proceeding in this body since 1798
indeed to signify the
importance of the occasion the senate's
more recent traditions call for you as
you did to sign the book and that book
is not simply part of the record its
entrusted to the National Archives
in contrast members of the House of
Representatives do not take an oath in
connection with impeachment the framers
of our Constitution well knew when an
oath or affirmation should be required
the Senate yes the house No and thus
each member of the world's greatest
deliberative body now has special indeed
unique duties and obligations duties
imposed under our founding document
during the Clinton impeachment trial
twenty-one years ago in this chamber the
Chief Justice of the United States ruled
in response to an objection that was
interposed by Senator Tom Harkin of Iowa
the Senators are not sitting as jurors
so your Harkin noted and the Chief
Justice agreed with that proposition
rather the Senate is a court in fact
history teaches us that for literally
decades this body was referred to in
this context as the high court of
impeachment so we're not in a
legislative chamber during these
proceedings we're in a tribunal we're in
court in Federalist 78 Alexander
Hamilton who's been quoted frequently in
these proceedings but in Federalist 78
he was describing the role of Courts
you're a role and in doing so he
distinguished between what he called the
exercise of
judgment on the one hand which is what
courts do and the exercise of will our
policy preferences if you will on the
other hand that's what legislative
bodies do according to Hamilton courts
were to be in his word impartial there's
that word again
I know that's a daunting task for judges
struggling to do the right thing to be
impartial equal justice under law it's
certainly hard in life to be impartial
in politics it's not even asked of one
to be impartial but that's the task that
the Constitution chose to impose upon
each of you and significantly in this
particular juncture in America's history
the Senate is being called to sit as the
high court of impeachment all too
frequently indeed we are living in what
I think can aptly be described as the
age of impeachment in the house
resolution after resolution month after
month has called for the president's
impeachment how did we get here with
presidential impeachment invoked
frequently in its inherently
destabilizing as well as acrimonious way
briefly told the story begins 42 years
ago in the wake of the long national
nightmare of Watergate Congress and
President Jimmy Carter collaboratively
ushered in a new chapter in America's
constitutional history together in full
agreement they enacted the Independent
Counsel provisions of the ethics and
Government Act of 1978
but the new chapter was not simply the
age of independent councils it became
unbeknownst to the American people the
age of impeachment during my service in
the Reagan administration as councilor
and chief of staff to Attorney General
William French Smith the Justice
Department took the position that
however well-intentioned the Independent
Counsel provisions were unconstitutional
why in the view of the department those
provisions intruded into the rightful
domain and prerogative of the executive
branch of the president's say the
Justice Department's position was
eventually rejected by the Supreme Court
but most importantly in helping us
understand this new era in our country's
history Justice Antonin Scalia was in
deep dissent among his stinging
criticisms of that law Justice Scalia
wrote this the context of this statute
is acrid with the smell of threatened
impeachment impeachment Justice Scalia
echoed the criticism of the court in
which I was serving at the time the
District of Columbia Circuit which it
actually struck down the law as
unconstitutional and a very impressive
opinion by renowned judge Lawrence
Silverman why why would Justice Scalia
refer to impeachment this was a reform
measure there would be no more Saturday
night massacres the firing of special
prosecutor as he was called Archibald
Cox by President Nixon government would
now be better more honest
greater accountability and the
independent counsel would be protected
but the word impeachment haunts that
dissenting opinion and it's not hard to
discover why because the statute by its
terms expressly directed the Independent
Counsel to become in effect an agent of
the House of Representatives and if what
in to report to the House of
Representatives when a very low
threshold of information was received
that an impeachable offense left
undefined may have been committed to
paraphrase President Clinton's very able
counsel at the time
Ernie Nussbaum this statute is a dagger
aimed at the heart of the presidency
President Clinton nonetheless signed the
reauthorized measure and law and the
nation then went through the long
process known as whitewater resulting in
the findings by the office which I led
the office of Independent Counsel in a
written report to the House of
Representatives that referral to
Congress was stipulated and the Ethics
in Government Act of 1978 to put it
mildly
Democrats were very upset about what had
happened they then joined Republicans
across the aisle who for their part had
been outraged by an earlier Independent
Counsel investigation that of a very
distinguished former judge Lawrence
Walsh during the Reagan administration
judge Walsh's investigation of what
became known to the country is
iran-contra spawned enormous criticism
on the Republican side of the
both as to the investigation itself but
also as to the statue the acrimony
surrounding iran-contra and then the
impeachment and the trial and President
Clinton's acquittal by this body led
inexorably to the end of the Independent
Counsel era enough was enough and living
through that wildly controversial 21
year bold experiment with the
Independent Counsel statute Congress in
a bipartisan way how to change apart it
allowed the law to expire in accordance
with its terms in 1999 that would be a
well-intentioned reform measure died a
quiet and uneventful death and it was
promptly replaced by Justice Department
internal regulations promulgated by
Attorney General Janet Reno during the
waning months of the Clinton
administration one can review those
regulations and see no reference to
impeachment none no longer were the
poison pill provisions of presidential
impeachment part of America's legal
landscape they were gone the reno
regulations seemed to signal a return to
traditional norms impeachment would no
longer be embedded in the actual laws of
the land but returned to the language of
the Constitution but in the meantime
America's constitutional DNA and its
political culture had changed even with
the dawn of the new century the 21st
century impeachment remained on the
of countless Americans and echoed
frequently in the people's house the
impeachment habit proved to be hard to
kick ironically while this was happening
here at home across the Atlantic the use
of impeachment as a weapon disappeared
in the United Kingdom from which of
course we inherited the process
impeachment was first used more than two
centuries before those first settlers
crossed the Atlantic but upon thoughtful
examination a number of modern-day
parliamentary committees looked and
found impeachment to be obsolete among
other criticisms members of parliament
came to the view that the practice which
had last been attempted in Britain in
1868 fails to meet modern procedural
standards of fairness fairness as Sir
William Mackay recently remarked
impeachment in Britain is dead yet here
at home and the world's longest standing
constitutional republic instead of a
once in a century phenomenon which it
had been presidential impeachment has
become a weapon to be wielded against
one's political opponent in her
thoughtful Wall Street Journal op-ed a
week ago Saturday Peggy Noonan wrote
this impeachment has now been normalized
it won't be a once-in-a-generation act
but in every administration act
Democrats will regret it
when Republicans are handing out the
pens depends of the signing ceremony
when we look back down the corridors of
time we see that for almost our first
century as a constitutional republic the
sword of presidential impeachment
remained sheathed had there been
controversial presidents oh yes indeed
think of John Adams in the Alien and
Sedition Acts think of Andrew Jackson
and Henry Clay were partisan passions
occasionally inflamed during that first
century of course unless there be any
doubt the early Congress is full well
knew how to summon impeachment to the
fore including against a member of this
body
senator William Blount of Tennessee
during the Jefferson administration
the unsuccessful impeachment of Justice
Samuel chase a surly impartial jurist
who was nonetheless acquitted by this
chamber became an early landmark in
maintaining the treasured independence
of our federal judiciary it took the
national convulsion of the Civil War the
Sassa nation of mr. Lincoln and the
counter reconstruction measures
aggressively pursued by mr. Lincoln's
successor Andrew Johnson to bring about
the nation's very first presidential
impeachment famously of course your
predecessors in this High Court of
impeachment acquitted the unpopular and
controversial Johnson but only by virtue
of senators from the party of Lincoln
breaking ranks it was over a century
later that the nation returned to the
tumultuous world up
presidential impeachment necessitated by
the ranked criminality of the Nixon
administration in light of the rapidly
unfolding facts including uncovered by
the Senate Select Committee and an
overwhelmingly bipartisan vote of 410 -
for the House of Representatives
authorized an impeachment inquiry and in
1974 the House Judiciary Committee after
lengthy hearings voted again in a
bipartisan manner to impeach the
President of the United States
importantly President Nixon's own party
was slowly but inexorably moving toward
favoring the removal of their chosen
leader from the nation's highest office
who had just won re-election by a
landslide it bears emphasis before this
High Court this was the first
presidential impeachment in over 100
years it also bears emphasis it was
powerfully bipartisan and it wasn't just
the vote to authorize the impeachment
inquiry indeed the house judiciary chair
Peter Rodino of New Jersey was insistent
that to be accepted by the American
people the process had to be bipartisan
like war impeachment is hell or at least
presidential impeachment is hell those
of us who live through the Clinton
impeachment including members of this
body full well understand that a
presidential impeachment is tantamount
to domestic war I'll bet
thankfully protected by our beloved
First Amendment
a war of words and a war of ideas but
it's filled with acrimony and it divides
the country like nothing else those of
us who live through the Clinton
impeachment month understand that at a
deep and personal way now in contrast
wisely and judiciously conducted unlike
the United Kingdom impeachment remains a
vital and appropriate tool in our
country to serve as a check with respect
to the federal judiciary after all and
the Constitution's brilliant structural
design federal and judges know as this
body full well knows from its daily work
a pivotally important feature
independence from politics exactly what
Alexander Hamilton was talking about in
Federalist 78 during the Constitution's
term good behavior in practical effect
life tenure impeachment is thus a very
important protection for We the People
against what could be serious article 3
wrongdoing within that branch and so it
is that when you count of the 63
impeachment inquiries author ID for the
House of Representatives over our
history only eight have actually been
convicted in this High Court and removed
from office and each and every one has
been a federal judge this history leads
me to reflect on the nature of your
weighty responsibilities here in this
High Court as judges in the context of
presidential impeachment the fourth
presidential impeachment I'm counting
the Nixon proceedings and our nation's
history
but the third over the past half-century
and I respectfully submit that the
Senate in its wisdom would do well in
its deliberations to guide the nation in
this world's greatest deliberative body
to return to our country's traditions
when President President impeachment was
truly a measure of last resort members
of this body can help and end this very
proceeding restore our constitutional
and historical traditions above all by
returning to the text of the
Constitution itself it can do so by its
example here in these proceedings in
weaving the tapestry of what can rightly
be called the common law of presidential
impeachment that's what courts do they
weave the common law there are
indications within the constitutional
text or come to our history that this
fundamental question is appropriate to
be asked you're familiar with the
arguments was there a crime or other
violation of established law alleged so
let's turn to the text throughout the
Constitution's description of
impeachment the text speaks always
always without exception in terms of
crimes it begins of course with treason
the greatest of crimes against the state
and against we the people but so misused
as a bludgeon and parliamentary
experiences to lead the founders to
actually define the term and the
Constitution itself
bribery an iniquitous form of moral and
legal corruption and the basis of so
many of the sixty-three impeachment
proceed
over the course of our history again
almost all of them against judges and
then the mysterious terms other high
crimes and misdemeanors
once again the language is employing the
language of crimes the Constitution is
speaking to us in terms of crimes each
of those references when you count them
count seven count eight supports the
conclusion that impeachments should be
evaluated in terms of offenses against
established law but especially with
respect to the presidency where the
Constitution requires the Chief Justice
the United States and not a political
officer no matter how honest no matter
how impartial to preside a trial
guided by history the framers made a
deliberate and wise choice to cabin to
constrain to limit the power of
impeachment and so it was on the very
eve of the impeachment of President
Andrew Johnson the eminent scholar and
Dean of the Columbia Law School theodore
dwight wrote this the weight of
authority is that no impeachment will
lie except for a true crime a breach of
the law which would be the subject of
indictment I'm not making that argument
I'm noting what he is saying he didn't
over argue the case he said the weight
of authority the weight of authority and
so this issue is a weighty one has the
house of representatives with all due
respect in these two articles of
impeachment charged a crime or violation
of established law or not
this is I don't to over argue an
appropriate
weighty consideration for the Senate but
especially as I'm trying to emphasize in
the case not of a federal judge but of
the president courts consider Prudential
factors and there is a huge potential
factor that this trial is occurring in
an election year when we the people in a
matter of months will go to the polls in
developing the common law of
presidential impeachment this threshold
factor consistent with the
constitutional text consistent with the
nation's history and presidential
impeachments as I'll seek to demonstrate
serves as a clarifying and stabilizing
element
it increases predictability to do what
to reduce the profound danger that a
presidential impeachment will be
dominated by partisan considerations
precisely the evil that the framers
warned about and so to history history
bears out the point the nation's most
recent experience the Clinton
impeachment
even though severely and roundly
criticized charged crimes these are
crimes proven and the crucible the House
of Representatives debate beyond any
reasonable observers doubt so to the
Nixon impeachment the articles charged
crimes
what about article 2 in Nixon which is
sometimes referred to as abuse of power
was that the abuse of power article the
precursor to article 1 that is before
this Court
not at all when one returns to article 2
in Nixon approved by a bipartisan the
House Judiciary Committee
article two of Nixon sets forth a deeply
troubling story of numerous crimes not
one not two numerous crimes carried out
at the direction of the President
himself and so the appropriate question
were crimes alleged in the articles in
the common law of presidential
impeachment in Nixon yes in Clinton yes
here no a factor to be considered as the
judges in the High Court come as you
will individually to your judgment even
in the political cauldron of the Andrew
Johnson impeachment article eleven
charged a violation of the controversial
tenure of office Act you're familiar
with it
and that act warn't expressly the Oval
Office
that it's violation would constitute a
high misdemeanor employing the very
language of constitutionally cognizable
crimes this history represents and I
believe may it please the court it
embodies the common law of presidential
impeachment these are facts gleaned from
the constitutional text and from the
gloss of the nation's history and under
this view the commission of an alleged
crime or violation of established law
can appropriately be considered again a
weighty and an important consideration
and element of an historically
supportable presidential impeachment
will law professors agree with this no
but with all due respect to the Academy
this is not an academic gathering we're
in court we're not just in court with
all due respect to the Chief Justice and
the Supreme Court of the United States
we're in democracy's ultimate court and
the better constitutional answer to the
question is provided by a rigorous and
faithful examination of the
constitutional text and then looking
faithfully and respectfully to our
history the very divisive Clinton
impeachment demonstrates that while
highly relevant the commission of a
crime is by no means sufficient to
warrant the removal of our duly elected
president why this body knows we appoint
judges and you confirm them and they're
there for life not presidents and the
presidency is unique the presidency
stands alone in our constitutional
framework before he became the Chief
Justice of the United States John
Marshall then sitting as a member of the
people's house made a speech on the
floor of the house
and there he said this the president is
the sole organ of the nation in its
external relations and its sole
representative with foreign nations if
that sounds like hyperbole it has been
embraced over decades by the Supreme
Court of the United States by justices
appointed by many different presidents
the presidency is unique there's no
other system quite like ours and it has
served us well and so as to the
presidency impeachment and removal not
only overturns a national election
and perhaps profoundly affects an
upcoming election in the words of Yale's
Akhil amar it entails a risk and these
are a Kiehl's words professor Mars words
grave disruption of the government
professor amar pinned those words in
connection with the Clinton impeachment
grave disruption of the government
regardless of what the president has
done grave disruption we will all agree
that the Presidents under the text of
the Constitution and it's amendments are
to serve out their term absent a genuine
national consensus reflected by the
two-thirds majority requirement of this
court that the president must go away
two-thirds in politics and an
impeachment that's called a landslide
here I respectfully submit to the court
that all fair-minded persons will surely
agree there is no national consensus we
might wish for one but there isn't to
the contrary for the first time in
America's modern history
not a single House member of the
president's parties supported either of
the two articles of impeachment not one
not in committee not on the House floor
and that pivotal fact puts in bold
relief the Peter Rodino principle call
it the Rodino rule impeachment must be
bipartisan in nature again sitting as a
court this body should signal to the
nation the return to our traditions
by partisan impeachments what's the
alternative will the president be king
do oversight the tradition of oversight
an enormous check on presidential power
throughout our history and it continues
available today in iran-contra no
impeachment was undertaken the Speaker
of the House a Democrat Jim Wright from
Texas from Fort Worth where the West
begins knew better he said no but his
befits the age of impeachment
a House Resolution to impeach President
Ronald Reagan was introduced it was
filed and the effort to impeach
President Reagan was supported by a
leading law professor whose name you
would well recognize and you will hear
it again this evening from professor
Dershowitz I'll leave it to him
to identify the learner professor but
the speaker of the people's house
echoing Peter Rodino said no so I
respectfully submit that the Senate
should close this chapter this
idiosyncratic chapter on this
increasingly disruptive act this era
this age of resort to the Constitution's
ultimate democratic weapon for the
presidency let the people decide
there was a great Justice who sat for 30
years Justice John Harlan in this
mid-century of the 20th century and in a
law suit involving a very basic question
considers as whose rights have clearly
been violated
by federal law enforcement agencies and
agents bring an action for damages when
Congress has not so provided no law that
gave the wounded citizen a right to
redress through damages and justice
Harlan in a magnificent concurring
opinion in Bivens versus six unnamed
federal agents suggested that courts
here you are should take into
consideration in reaching its judgment
of their judgment what he called factors
counseling restraint he was somewhat
reluctant to say that we the Supreme
Court should grant this right that we
should create it when Congress has
enacted and Congress could have acted
but it hadn't but he reluctantly came to
the conclusion that the Constitution
itself empowered the federal courts to
create this right for our injured
citizens to give them redress not just
an injunctive relief but damages money
recovery for violations of their
constitutional rights factors counseling
restraint and he addressed them and he
came to the view he was so honest and
said I came to the case with a different
view but I changed my mind and voted in
favor of the Bivens family having
redress against the federal agents who
had violated their rights judging and
it's most impartial and elegant sense
I'm going to draw from justice Harlan's
matrix of factors counseling restrain
and simply identify these I think there
may be others the articles do not charge
a crime or violation of established law
I'm suggesting it's a relevant factor I
think
it's a weighty factor when we come to
presidential impeachment not judicial in
feature secondly the articles come to
you with no bipartisan support they come
to you as a violation of what I'm
dubbing the Rodino rule and third is I
will now discuss the pivotally important
issue of process the second article of
impeachment obstruction of Congress this
Court is very familiar with United
States versus Nixon its unanimity and
recognizing the president's profound
interest in confidentiality regardless
of the worldview or philosophy of the
Justice the justices were unanimous this
isn't just a contrivance it's built into
the very nature of our constitutional
order so let me comment briefly this
constitutionally based recognition of
executive privilege and then companion
privileges the deliberative process
privilege the immunity of close
presidential advisors from being
summoned to testify these are all firmly
established in our law if there is a
dispute between the people's house and
the president United States over the
availability of documents or witnesses
and there is in each and every
administration then go to court it
really is as simple as that I don't need
to belabor the point but here's the
point I would like to emphasize
frequently the Justice Department
advises the president of the United
States that the protection of the
presidency calls whatever the president
might want to do as a political matter
as an accommodation and spirit of comedy
to protect privileged conversations and
communications I've heard it in my two
tours of duty at the Justice Department
don't release the documents mr.
president if you do you're injuring the
president's e-coat accord we've we've
heard concerns about the length of time
that the litigation might take those of
us who have litigated know that
sometimes litigation does take longer
than we would like justice delayed is
justice denied we would all agree with
that but our history
Churchill's Maxim study history our
history tells us that's not necessarily
so take by way of example the Pentagon
Papers case orders issued preventing and
sanctioning a gross violation of the
First Amendment's guarantee of freedom
of the press an order issued out of the
district court June the 15th 1971 that
order was reversed in an opinion by the
Supreme Court of the United States
two weeks later June the 15th the House
of Representatives could have followed
that well-trodden path it could have
sought expedition the Iberico dominant
Prettyman courthouse is six blocks down
the judges are there they're all very
able they're hard-working people of
integrity
follow the path follow the path of the
law go to court
there would have been at least one
problem had the house seen fit to go to
court and remain in court the issue is
before you
but among other flaws the office of
legal counsel determined and I've read
the opinion and I believe it's correct
that with all respect all house
subpoenaed issued prior to the adoption
of House Resolution 661 authorized the
impeachment inquiry as a house all
subpoenas were invalid they were void
with all due respect to the Speaker of
the House of Representatives and all of
her abilities in her vast experience
under our Constitution she was powerless
to do what she purported to do as has
been said now time and again especially
throughout the fall the Constitution
does entrust the sole power of
impeachment to the House of
Representatives but that's the house
it's 435 members elected from across the
constitutional republic not one no
matter how able she may be in the
people's house every Congress person
gets a vote we know the concept one
person one vote more generally the
president is I've reviewed the record as
consistently and scrupulously followed
the advice and counsel of the Justice
Department and in particular the office
of legal counsel he's been obedient as
you know that important office many of
you have had your own experiences
professionally with that office is
staffed with lawyers of great ability
it has a reputation for superb work it
has done such thoughtful work in both
Democratic and Republican
administrations and the office is now
headed by a brilliant lawyer who served
as a law clerk to Justice Anthony
Kennedy the house may disagree with the
guidance provided to the president by
that office the house frequently does
disagree but for the president to follow
the guidance of the Department of
Justice with respect to an inter branch
legal and constitutional dispute cannot
reasonably be viewed as an obstruction
and most emphatically not as an
impeachable offense history once again
is a great teacher in the Clinton
impeachment the House Judiciary
Committee rejected a draft article
asserting that President Clinton and
here were the words of the draft article
fraudulently and corruptly asserted
executive privilege strong words
fraudulently and corruptly that was the
draft article and my view having lived
through the facts and with all due
respect to the former president he did
he did it time and again
month after month we would go to court
we would win
and many members not everybody on the
House Judiciary Committee agreed that
the president had indeed improperly
claimed executive privilege rebuffed
time it again by the judiciary but at
the end of the day that committee
chaired the Judiciary Committee of the
house chaired by henry hyde wisely
concluded that president clinton's doing
so should not be considered an
impeachable offense here's the idea it
is not an impeachable offense for the
President of the United States to defend
the asserted legal and constitutional
prerogatives of the presidency this is
and I'm quoting here from page 55 of the
president's trial brief a function of
his constitutional and policy judgments
not just a policy judgment but a
constitutional judgment I would guide
this court as it's coming through the
deliberation process to read the
president's trial brief with respect to
process it was Justice Felix Frankfurter
confidant of FDR brilliant jurist who
reminded America that the history of
Liberty is in large measure the history
of process of procedure in particular I
would guide the High Court to the
discussion of the long history of the
House of Representatives over two
centuries in providing due process
protections in its impeachment
investigations
it's a richly historical discussion the
good news is you can read the core of it
in four pages pages 62 to 60
six of the trial brief puts in bold
relief I believe an irrefutable fact
this house of representatives with all
respect saw fit to turn its back on its
on established procedures procedures
that had been followed faithfully decade
after decade regardless of who was in
control regardless of political party
all those procedures were torn asunder
and all over the vigorous objections
from the unanimous and vocal minority I
need not remind this High Court that in
this country minority rights are
important minority rights should be
protected equal justice but then again
the House members took no oath to be
impartial the Constitution didn't
require them to say by oath or
affirmation that will do impartial
judges justice when they chose to tear
asunder their procedures they were oath
less they could toss out their own
rulebook raw power and here we have
tragically for the country and I believe
tragically for the House of
Representatives in article 2 of these
impeachment articles a runaway house it
is runaway not only from its
long-standing procedures it is run away
from the Constitution's demand of
fundamental fairness captured in those
hallowed terms due process of law we've
cared about this as an english-speaking
people since Magna Carta by doing so
however the House has inadvertently
pointed this court to an exit ramp
it's an exit ramp provided by the
Constitution itself it's an exit ramp
built by the most noble of builders the
founding generation
despite the clearest precedent requiring
due process for the accused in an
impeachment inquiry but surely all the
more so and a presidential impeachment
House Democrats chose to conduct a
wholly unprecedented process in this
case and they did so knowingly and
deliberately because they were warned at
every turn don't do it don't do it that
way
and process the president being denied
the basic rights that have been afforded
to every single accused president in the
history of the Republic even to the
racist Andrew Johnson seeking to undo
mr. Lincoln's great legacy he got those
rights but not here due process could
have been honored basic rights could
have been honored the house rules the
houses traditions could have been
honored but what's done is done
these two articles come before this
court this High Court of impeachment
dripping with fundamental process
violations when courts inure the court
are confronted with this kind of
phenomenon a train of fairness
violations courts in this country do the
right thing they do impartial justice
they invoke
figuratively or literally the words of
the preamble to America's Constitution
the very first order of our government
after to form a more perfect union is to
establish justice to establish justice
even before getting to the words to
provide for the common defense to
promote the general welfare to ensure
domestic tranquility the Constitution
speaks in terms of justice establishing
justice courts would not allow this they
would not allow this because why they
knew and they know that the purpose of
our founding instrument is to protect
our liberties to safeguard us but to
safeguard us as individuals against the
powers of government and why in the
benedictory words of the preamble to
secure the blessings of liberty to
ourselves and our posterity liberty
under law I thank the court
mr. Sekulow
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
house managers Judge Starr laid out
before you the solemn nature of these
proceedings I want to contrast the
solemn nature of these proceedings and
what has been laid out before us from a
both historical and constitutional
perspective and I want you to think
about this the history the importance
the solemnity of what we're engaged in
here in this great body with what took
place in the House of Representatives
upon the signing of articles of
impeachment pens distributed to the
impeachment managers a celebratory
moment think about that
think about this
a poignant moment we're next going to
address a factual analysis to briefly
reflect my colleague the deputy White
House Counsel Mike Perot will be joining
us in a moment to discuss more of the
facts to continue the discussion that we
had on Saturday but let me just recap
very quickly what was laid out on
Saturday
first the transcript shows that the
President did not condition either
Security Assistance or a meeting on
anything the pause security assistant
funds aren't even mentioned on the call
second president Solinsky and other
Ukrainian officials repeatedly said
there was no quid pro quo and no
pressure on them to review anything
third president Solinsky and
high-ranking Ukrainian officials did not
even know the security assistance was
paused till the end of August over a
month after the July 25th call forth not
a single witness testified that the
President himself said that there was
any connection between any investigation
and security assistance a presidential
meeting or anything else fifth the
security assistance flowed on September
11th and a presidential meeting took
place on September 25th without the
Ukrainian government without Ukrainian
government announcing any investigations
finally in the blind drive to impeach
the president president and Trump in
reality strategically has been the best
friend and supporter of Ukraine
certainly in our recent history these
are the facts that is what's before you
deputy white House Counsel Mike purpura
will now address additional facts
related to these proceedings thank you
mr. chief justice
members of the Senate good afternoon mr.
leader I believe that we will be ready
to take a break at the conclusion of my
remarks if it meets with your approval
on Saturday we walked through some of
the evidence that the house managers put
forward and didn't put forward during
their 21 plus hours of presentation that
evidence that we recounted was drawn
directly from the house managers own
record the case they chose to submit to
this chamber to echo my colleague mr.
Sekulow briefly the house managers own
evidence shows the president Trump did
not condition anything on investigations
during the July 25 call with president
Solinsky and did not even mention the
pause security assistance on the call
president Solinsky said that he felt no
pressure on the call president Solinsky
and the top Ukrainian officials did not
learn of the pause on the security
assistance until more than a month after
the July 25 call and the house managers
own record their record that they
developed and brought before this
chamber reflects that anyone who spoke
with the president said that the
president made clear that there was no
linkage between security assistance and
investigations there's another category
of evidence demonstrating that the pause
on security assistance was distinct and
unrelated to investigations the
president released the aid without the
Ukrainians ever announcing any
investigations or undertaking
any investigations here is ambassador
sunland and the fact is the aid was
given to Ukraine without any
announcement of new investigations
that's correct
and president Trump did in fact meet
with President Solinsky in September at
the United Nations correct he did and
there was no announcement of
investigations before this meeting
correct and there was no announcement of
investigations after this meeting that's
right so while the Security Assistance
was paused the administration did
precisely what you would expect it
addressed president Trump's concerns
about the two issues that I mentioned on
Saturday burden-sharing and corruption a
number of law and policy makers also
contacted the president and the White
House to provide input on the security
assistance issue during this period
including Senator Lindsey Graham the
process culminated on September 11
2019 on that day the president spoke
with vice president pence and Senator
Rob Portman the Vice President in NSC
senior director Tim Morrison's words was
armed with his conversation with
President zalenski from their meeting
just days earlier in Warsaw Poland and
both the vice president and Senator
Portman related their view of the
importance of the assistance to Ukraine
and convinced the president that the age
should be dispersed immediately after
the meeting President Trump terminated
the pause and the support flowed to
Ukraine I want to take a step back now
and talk for a moment about why the
security assistance was briefly paused
again in the words of the house managers
own witnesses witness after witness
testified that confronting Ukrainian
corruption
be at the forefront of United States
foreign policy toward Ukraine they also
testified that the president had
long-standing and sincere concerns about
corruption in Ukraine the house managers
however told you that it was laughable
to think that the president cared about
corruption in Ukraine but that's not
what the witnesses said according to
ambassador Volcker president Trump
demonstrated that he had a very deeply
rooted negative view of Ukraine based on
past corruption and that's a reasonable
position according to ambassador Volcker
most people who know anything about
Ukraine would think that and dr. hill
testified I think the president has
actually quite publicly said that he was
very skeptical about corruption in
Ukraine and in fact he's not alone
because everyone has expressed great
corrupt great concerns about corruption
in Ukraine the house managers have said
that the president's concern with
corruption is disingenuous
they said that President Trump didn't
care about corruption in 2017 or 2018
and he certainly didn't care about it in
2019 that was their words
not according to ambassador Jovanovic
however who testified that President
Trump shared his concern about
corruption directly with President
poroshenko president zelinsky's
predecessor in their first meeting in
the Oval Office when was that meeting in
June of 2017 2017
the president also has well-known
concerns about foreign aid generally
scrutinizing and in some cases
curtailing foreign aid was a central
plank of his campaign platform President
Trump is especially wary of sending
American taxpayer dollars abroad when
other countries refuse to pitch in mr.
Morrison and mr. Hale both testified at
length about president Trump's
long-standing concern with burden
sharing in foreign aid programs here's
what they said the the president was
concerned that the United States seemed
to to bear the exclusive brunt of
security assistance to Ukraine he wanted
to see the Europeans step up and
contribute more security assistance
we've all often heard at the State
Department that the president knighted
States wants to make sure that foreign
assistance is reviewed scrupulously to
make sure that it's in truly in US
national interests and that we evaluated
continuously so that it meets certain
criteria that the president's
established and has the president
expressed that he expects our allies to
give their fair share of foreign aid as
evidenced by a point that he raised
during the July 25th phone call with
President szalinski to that effect the
principle of greater burden sharing by
allies and other like-minded states is
an important element of the foreign
assistance review the president
expressed these precise concerns to
Senator Ron Johnson who wrote he
reminded me how thoroughly corrupt
Ukraine was and again conveyed his
frustration that Europe doesn't do its
fair share of providing military aid the
house managers didn't tell you about
this why not and president Trump was
right to be concerned that other
countries weren't paying their fair
share as Laura Cooper testified u.s.
contributions to Ukraine are far more
significant than any individual country
and she also said 'hey you funds tend to
be on the economic side rather than for
defense and security
senator Johnson also confirmed that
other countries refused to provide the
lethal defensive weapons that Ukraine
needs in its war with Russia please keep
in mind also that the pause of the
Ukraine Security Assistance Program was
far from unusual or out of character for
president Trump the American people know
that the president is skeptical of
foreign aid and that one of his top
campaign promises and priorities in
office has been to avoid wasteful
spending of American taxpayer dollars
abroad meanwhile the same people who
today claimed that President Trump was
not genuinely concerned about
burden-sharing
were upset when as a candidate president
Trump criticized free-riding by NATO
members this past summer the
administration paused reviewed and in
some cases canceled hundreds of millions
of dollars in foreign aid to Afghanistan
El Salvador Honduras Guatemala and
Lebanon and these are just some of the
reviews of foreign aid undertaken at the
very same time that the Ukraine aid was
paused so what happened during the brief
period of time while the Ukraine's
security assistance was paused people
were gathering information and
monitoring the facts on the ground in
Ukraine as the new Parliament was sworn
in and began introducing anti-corruption
legislation notwithstanding what the
house managers would have you believe
the reason for the pause was no secret
within the White House and the agencies
according to mr. Morrison in a July
meeting attended by officials throughout
the executive branch agencies the reason
provided for the pause by a
representative of the Office of
Management and Budget
was that the
was concerned about corruption in
Ukraine and he wanted to make sure that
Ukraine was doing enough to manage that
corruption in fact as mr. Morrison
testified by Labor Day
there had been definitive developments
to demonstrate that President zalenski
was committed to the issues he
campaigned on anti-corruption reforms Mr
Morrison also testified that the
administration was working on answering
the president's concerns regarding
burden sharing here's mr. Morrison was
there any interagency activity whether
it be with the State Department or the
Defense Department and coordination by
the National Security Council to look
into that a little bit for the president
we were surveying the the data to
understand who was contributing what and
sort of in what categories and so the
president evinced concerns the
interagency tried to address them yes
how else do we know that the president
was awaiting information on burden
sharing and anti-corruption efforts in
Ukraine before releasing the security
assistance because that's what
vice-president pence told President
Solinsky on September 1 2019 vice
president pence met with President
zalenski
President Trump was scheduled to attend
the World War two commemoration in
Poland but instead remained in the u.s.
to manage the emergency response to
Hurricane durian remember this was three
days three days after President zalenski
learned through the political article
about the review of the security
assistance just as vice president pence
and his aides anticipated Jennifer
Williams testified that once the cameras
left the room the very first question
that president president Solinsky had
was about the status of the security
assistance the vice president responded
by asking about
things burden-sharing and corruption
here's how Jennifer Williams described
it the VP responded by really expressing
our ongoing support for Ukraine but
wanting to hear from president zalenski
you know what the status of his reform
efforts were that he could then convey
back to the President and also wanting
to hear if there was more that European
countries could do to support Ukraine
vice president pence knows President
Trump and he knew what President Trump
wanted to hear from President Solinsky
the Vice President was echoing the
president's to recurring themes
corruption and burden-sharing
it's the same consistent themes every
time ambassador Taylor received a
similar readout of the meeting between
the vice president and president
Solinsky including the vice president's
focus on corruption and burden-sharing
here's ambassador Taylor on the evening
of September 1st
I received a readout of the pencil insky
meeting over the phone from mr. Morrison
during which he told me that the
presidents of Linsky had opened the
meeting by immediately asking vice
president about the security cooperation
the vice president did not respond
substantively but said that he would
talk to President Trump that night the
Vice President did say that President
Trump one of the Europeans to do more to
support Ukraine and that he wanted the
Ukrainians to do more to fight
corruption on September 11 based on the
information collected and presented to
President Trump the president lifted the
pause on the security assistance as Mr
Morrison explained our process gave the
president the confidence he needed to
approve the release of the security
sector assistance the house managers say
that the talk about corruption and
burden sharing is a ruse no one knew why
the security assistance was paused and
no one was addressing the president's
concerns with Ukrainian corruption and
burden sharing the house managers
own evidence their own record tells a
different story however they didn't tell
you about this not in 21 hours why not
the president's concerns were addressed
in the ordinary course the president
wasn't caught as the house managers
allege the managers are wrong
all of this together with what we
discussed on Saturday demonstrates that
there was no connection between security
assistance and investigations when house
managers realized that their quid pro
quo theory on security assistance was
falling apart they created a second
alternative theory according to the
house managers president zalenski
desperately wanted a meeting at the
White House with President Trump and
president Trump conditioned that meeting
on investigations so what about the
managers backup accusations do they fare
any better than their quid pro quo for
security assistance no no they don't
a presidential level meeting happened
without any preconditions at the first
available opportunity in a widely
televised meeting at the United Nations
General Assembly in New York on
September 25 2019 the White House was
working to scheduled a meeting earlier
at the White House or in Warsaw
but those options fell through due to
normal scheduling and a hurricane the
two presidents met at the earliest
convenience without president zalenski
ever announcing or beginning any
investigations the first thing to know
about the alleged quid pro quo for a
meeting is that by the end of the July
25 call the president had invited
president zalenski to the White House on
three separate occasions each time
without any preconditions
president Trump invited president
Solinsky to an in-person meeting on
their initial April 21 call when you're
settled in and ready I'd like to invite
you to the White House on May 29 the
week after President zelinsky's
inauguration President Trump sensitive
sent a congratulatory letter again
inviting presidents Lensky to the White
House as you prepare to address the many
challenges facing Ukraine please know
that the American people are with you
and are committed to helping Ukraine
realize its vast potential to help show
that commitment I would like to invite
you to meet with me at the White House
in Washington DC as soon as we can find
a mutually convenient time then on July
25th president Trump personally invited
president Solinsky to participate in a
meeting for a third time whenever you
would like to come to the White House
feel free to call give us a date and
we'll work that out I look forward to
seeing you that's three separate
invitations for a meeting all made
without any preconditions during this
time and behind the scenes the White
House was working diligently to schedule
a meeting between the presidents at the
earliest possible date Tim Morrison
whose responsibilities included helping
arrange head of state visits to the
White House or other head of state
meetings testified that he understood
that arranging the White House visit
with President zalenski was a due out
that came from the president the house
managers didn't mention the work that
the White House was doing to scheduled a
meeting between President Trump and
President zalenski did they why not
scheduling a presidential meeting takes
time Mr Morrison testified that his
Directorate which was just one of
several had a dozen scheduled requests
in with the president for meetings with
foreign leaders that we were looking to
land
and Ukraine was but one of those
requests due to both presidents busy
schedules according to mr. Morrison it
became clear that the earliest
opportunity for the two presidents to
meet would be in Warsaw at the beginning
of September the entire notion that a
bilateral meeting between President
Trump and president szalinski was
somehow conditioned on a statement about
investigations is completely defeated by
one straightforward fact a bilateral
meeting between President Trump and
president szalinski was planned for
September 1 in Warsaw
the same Warsaw meeting we were just
discussing without the Ukrainians saying
a word about investigations as it turned
out President Trump was not able to
attend the meeting in Warsaw because of
Hurricane Dorian President Trump asked
vice president Pence to attend in his
place
but even that scheduling glitch did not
put off their meeting for long President
Trump and president Solinsky met at the
next available date September 25 on the
sidelines of the United Nations General
Assembly as president zalenski himself
has said there were no preconditions for
his meeting with President Trump those
are his words no conditions so you're
probably wondering how could the house
managers claim that there was a quid pro
quo for a meeting with President Trump
when the two presidents actually did
meet without president Solinsky
announcing any investigations well the
house managers moved the goal posts
again they claimed that the meeting
couldn't be just an in-person meeting
with President Trump what it had to be
was a meeting at the Oval Office and in
the White House that's nonsense
putting to one side the absurdity
of the house managers trying to remove a
duly elected president of the United
States from office because he met a
world leader in one location versus
another this theory has no basis in fact
as dr. hill testified what mattered was
that there was a bilateral presidential
meeting not the location of the meeting
she said it wasn't always a White House
meeting per se but definitely a
presidential level you know meeting with
zalenski and the president I mean it
could have taken place in Poland in
Warsaw it could have been you know a
proper bilateral in some other context
but in other words a White House level
presidential meeting the house managers
didn't tell you about dr. Hills
testimony why not in fact they said just
last week that president zalenski still
hasn't gotten his White House meeting
why didn't they tell you about dr. hills
testimony so you would have the full
context and information they spoke for
over 21 hours they couldn't take a
couple of minutes to give you that
context how else do we know that dr.
hill was right because president
Solinsky said so on the July 25 call
remember when President Trump invited
president Solinsky to Washington on the
July 25 call presidents Lensky said he
would be happy to meet with you
personally and offered to host President
Trump in Ukraine or on the other hand
meet with President Trump on September 1
in Poland that's exactly what the
administration planned to do if it
weren't for hurricane Dorian President
Trump would have met with President
zalenski in Poland on September 1 just
as president zalenski had requested and
without any preconditions as it happened
president Solinsky met with the vice
president instead and just a few weeks
later met with President ROM
in New York all without anyone making
any statement about any investigations
and once again not a single witness in
the house record that they compiled and
developed under their procedures that
we've discussed and will continue to
discuss provided any first-hand evidence
that the president ever linked the
presidential meeting to any
investigations the house managers have
seized upon ambassador saltlands claim
that mr. Giuliani's requests were a quid
pro quo for arranging a White House
visit for President Solinsky but again
ambassador Sunland was only guessing
based on incomplete information he
testified that the president never told
him that there was any sort of a
condition for a meeting with President
Solinsky why then did he think there was
one in his own words
ambassador Sandlin said that he could
only repeat what he heard through
ambassador Volker from Giuliani so he
didn't even hear from mr. Giuliani
himself but ambassador Volcker who is
the supposed link between mr. Giuliani
and ambassador Sandland thought no such
thing
ambassador Volcker testified
unequivocally that there was no linkage
between the meeting with President
Solinsky and Ukrainian investigations
I'm gonna read the full questions and
answers because this passage is key this
is from ambassador Volkers deposition
testimony question did President Trump
ever withhold a meeting with President
Solinsky or delay a meeting with
President zalenski until the Ukrainians
committed to investigate the allegations
that you just described
concerning the 2016 presidential
election answer the answer to the
question is no if you want a yes or no
answer but the reason the answer is no
is we
did have difficulties scheduling a
meeting but there was no linkage like
that question you said that you were not
aware of any linkage between the delay
in the Oval Office meeting between
President Trump and presidents Lenski
and the Ukrainian commitment to
investigate the two allegations as you
described them correct answer correct on
no fewer than 15 separate occasions over
the past week the house managers played
a video of ambassador Sandland saying
that the announcement of the
investigations was a prerequisite for a
meeting or call with the president 15
times they never once read to you the
testimony that I just did they never
once read to you the testimony in which
ambassador Volcker refuted what
ambassador Sunland claimed he heard from
ambassador Volcker so here's what we
know president Trump invited president
zalenski to meet three times without
preconditions the White House was
working behind the scenes to schedule
the meeting the two presidents planned
to meet in Warsaw just as president
Solinsky had asked and ultimately met
three weeks later without Ukraine
announcing any investigations no one
testified in the House record that the
president ever said there was a
connection between a meeting and
investigations those are the facts plain
and simple so much for a quid pro quo
for a meeting with the president before
I move on let me take a brief moment to
address a side allegation that was
raised in the original whistleblower
complaint and that the house managers
are still trying to push the managers
claim that President Trump ordered vice
president Pence not to attend president
solinsky's inauguration in favor of a
lower-ranking delegation in order
according to them to signal a
downgrading of the relationship between
the United States and Ukraine that's not
true
numerous factors had to align as I'm
sure everyone in this room can greatly
appreciate for the vice president to
attend first dates of travel were
limited for national security reasons
the President and Vice President
generally avoid being out of the country
at the same time for more than a few
hours the president had scheduled trips
to Europe and Japan during the period
when our Embassy in Ukraine anticipated
the Ukrainian inauguration would occur
at the end of May or in early June
Jennifer Williams testified that the
office of the vice president advised the
Ukrainians that if the vice president
were to participate in the inauguration
the ideal dates would be around May 29
May 30 May 31 or June 1 when the
president would be in the United States
she said if it wasn't one of those dates
it would be very difficult or impossible
for the vice president to attend second
the house managers act as if no other
priorities in the world could compete
for the administration's time the vice
president's office was simultaneously
planning a competing trip for May 30 in
Ottawa Canada to participate in an event
supporting passage of the United States
Mexico Canada agreement ultimately the
vice president traveled to Ottawa on May
30 to meet with Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau and to promote the passage of
the u.s. MCA this decision as you know
advanced the top administration priority
and an issue president Trump vigorously
supported what you did not hear from the
house managers was that the Ukrainian
inauguration dates did not go as planned
on May 16 May 16
the Ukrainians surprised everyone and
scheduled the inauguration for just four
days later on May 20 Monday May 20 so
think about that may 16 2010 to Ukraine
Jennifer Williams testified that it was
very short notice so it would have been
difficult for the vice president to
attend particularly since they hadn't
sent out the advance team George Kent
testified that the short notice left
almost no time for either proper
preparations or foreign delegations to
visit and that the State Department
scrambled on Friday the 17th to try and
figure out who is available mr. Kent
suggested that Secretary of Energy
Perry be the anchor for the delegation
as someone who is a person of stature
and whose job had relevance to our
agenda secretary Perry led the
delegation which also included
ambassador Sunland ambassador Volker and
Senator Johnson ambassador Volcker
testified that it was the largest
delegation from any country there and it
was a high-level one the house managers
didn't tell you this why not
the claim that the president instructed
the vice president not to attend
president solinsky's inauguration is
based on house manager assumptions with
no evidence that the president did
something wrong and finally as I'm
coming to the end if the evidence
doesn't show a quid pro quo what does it
show unfortunately for the house
managers one of the few things that all
of the witnesses agreed on was that
president Trump has strengthened the
relationship between the US and Ukraine
and he has been a more stalwart friend
to Ukraine and a more fierce opponent of
Russian aggression than President Obama
the house managers repeated
he claimed the president Trump doesn't
care about Ukraine they are attributing
views to President Trump that are
contrary to his actions more importantly
they are contrary to the house managers
own evidence but don't take my word for
it
ambassadors Jovanovic Taylor and Volker
all testified to the Trump
administration's positive new policy
toward Ukraine based especially on
president Trump's decision to provide
lethal aid to Ukraine ambassador Taylor
testified that President Trump's policy
toward Ukraine was a substantial
improvement over President Obama's
policy ambassador Volcker agreed that
America's policy towards Ukraine has
been strengthened under President Trump
whom he credited with approving each of
the decisions made along the way
ambassador Jovanovic testified that
President Trump's decision to provide
lethal weapons to Ukraine meant that our
policy actually got stronger over the
last three years she called the policy
shift that President Trump directed very
significant let's hear from ambassador
Taylor ambassador Volcker and ambassador
Jovanovic the Trump administration has
indeed provided substantial aid to
Ukraine in the form of defense of lethal
aid correct that is correct
and that is more so than the Obama
administration correct the lethal aid
yes president Trump approved to each of
the decisions made along the way
providing lethal defensive equipment and
the Trump administration strengthened
our policy by approving the provision to
Ukraine of anti-tank missiles known as
javelins
they are obviously tank busters and so
if the war with Russia all of a sudden
accelerated in some way and tanks come
over their horizon
javelins are a very serious weapon to
deal with that Ukraine is better
positioned to fight Russia today than it
was before President Trump took office
as a result the United States is safer
too
the house managers did not tell you
about this testimony from ambassadors
Taylor Volker in Jovanovic why not these
are the facts as drawn from the house
managers own record on which they
impeach the president this is why the
house managers first article of
impeachment must fail for the six
reasons I set forth when I began on
Saturday there was no linkage between
investigations and security assistance
or meeting on the July 25 call the
Ukrainians said there was no quid pro
quo and they felt no pressure the top
Ukrainians did not even know that
security assistance was paused until
more than a month after the July 25 call
the house managers record reflects that
anyone who spoke with the president said
that the president made clear that there
was no linkage the security assistance
flowed and the presidential meeting took
place all without any announcement of
investigations and president Trump has
enhanced America's support for Ukraine
in his three years in office these facts
all require that the first article of
impeachment fail you have already heard
and will continue to hear from my
colleagues on why the second article
must fail once again this is the case
that the house managers chose to bring
this is the evidence they brought before
the Senate the very heavy burden of
proof rests with them they say their
case is overwhelming and uncontested it
is not they say they have proven each of
the articles against President Trump
they have not the facts and evidence of
the case the house managers have brought
exonerate the president thank you for
your attention
and I think we're ready for a break the
majority leader is recognized as his
colleagues we'll take a 15-minute break
without objection